[Music]
over the last six months my team and i
have been checking out your best
restaurant nominations all over the
country
and tonight the competition continues
with one of britain's most popular
cuisines indian
curry is a national obsession and these
days we all expect really high standards
from our indian restaurants i spent a
lot of time out in india and learned
from myself what real good indian food
is all about so tonight's restaurants
are going to be bloody good to impress
me
from over 2 000 indian nominations i've
chosen what i think are the best two to
fight it out for a place in the
semi-finals
tonight from bradford the curry cattle
of the north it's prashard somebody
passed whatever i cook it from my heart
i love cooking they're going head to
head with world famous cuisine from the
london heavyweight the brilliant in
southall give me the prawns come on my
father was a
top chef in india he used to cook for
the maharajas this competition could be
the ultimate test for both my indian
contenders it'll be a battle to the very
end because only one restaurant can come
out on top
to find that winner both contenders will
face three challenging tests starting
with a coach load of 30 hungry diners
who'll arrive and order all at once
first they'll descend on the patel
family who run tiny prashad in bradford
there are over 60 indian restaurants
alone in this fantastic city but this
one is somewhat special the smallest
restaurant this competition but i think
it's going to give the big boys a
serious run for the money
hello bobby hi gordon good to see you
welcome to you very well thank you yeah
welcome twice
i've never had a vegetarian restaurant
in the competition
so i'm so excited
yeah i'm happy as well yeah in just
under half an hour my diner's gonna be
here they think they're coming
for an amazing lambooner so convert them
this place used to be a laundrette
now it's a 22-seat restaurant run by
kaushi patel with her son bobby and his
wife minal
being vegetarian what we put passion
into other restaurants offer as a side
dish we have to really step up we really
have to bring the flavours out give them
something totally different incredibly
minal the head chef had never cooked
professionally until she married bobby
moved to england and joined his mum in
the kitchen six years ago
she's not my daughter-in-law she's my
daughter
i can describe how much i love cooking
whatever i cook it from my heart that is
delicious one mouthful of that i feel
like i'm back in mumbai the exact same
for my diners please no i can't leave
that to waste i've got to eat some more
of that i'm sorry jesus we have huge
drive
huge ambition we didn't come into this
business thinking we're going to make
loads of money we came into the business
about showing the world how good we are
at food
now they must prove it
because my 30 diners are just minutes
away
they're all expecting a perfect meal and
everyone must be served in just two
hours
the pressure's on you big time and i
know this means a lot i can see it on
your face but here's your chance now to
really stamp your hole in this
competition good luck
all the hairs on the back of my neck
standing up right now
[Music]
oh god
wow
very nice right now imagine all right
ladies and gentlemen let's show the
world what prashad really is let's rock
let's show ramsay let's go
ramsay's best restaurant bring it on
to accommodate my guests bobby had to
squeeze an extra eight seats into the
tiny dining room
sorry a little bit of a small restaurant
but the food is fantastic i promise you
despite its size prashad has huge
ambitions to fly the flag for vegetarian
indian cuisine
first time in a vegetarian restaurant
yes let's hope it's a memorable
experience
i'm a confirmed carnivore so anything
without me isn't really classed as a
meal
my diners are going to be a hard crowd
to please
[Music]
and it'll take a massive team effort to
convert them okay here we go i need two
awesome mix for coral and i need three
person petties no problem okay mine like
the new girl on the block and i'm just
hoping that she can cope with such a
demand because she's the least
experienced
three person petty as a starter she's
serving coconut petties potato and
chickpea chat and spicy vegetable
pakoras for me leave that one make the
chat first
this will be the hardest service of
their lives
now i need now she may be inexperienced
but minell's got to drive this kitchen
like never before
but however hard manal pushes her team
they're barely able to keep up and this
is just the first course i told you
oh my god
just listen what i'm saying
[Music]
not too hot but just right every plate
clean
that's incredible number two table
number four all of them say fantastic
food really really happy thank you thank
you very much halfway there keep it
going guys yes big push on the main
courses now yeah
mommy
but the mains will be even harder every
deep fried curry and dosa pancake needs
to be precisely timed
only one hour left so you know i'm
getting panicked
[Music]
prasad small kitchen is going hell for
leather but these dishes just aren't
leaving fast enough mom well
yeah
how long do they normally wait between
courses roughly uh ten ten minutes yeah
so the kitchen decides that you can only
cook at such a space you know you got
one
so you've got grill large tables now
waiting for main courses yeah
i need now i said that
quickly
the pressure's really on and some diners
have been waiting for an hour
just to let you know guys that um this
afternoon obviously we have all 30
guests in at once there may be a little
bit of a wait for your mains i hope you
can be patient with us
just said be patient which is fine it's
understandable so
i'm still having a good time
i've explained to them they're fine
about the fact that it'll be a little
while but obviously there is a deadline
on how much time we've got to serve
somebody pass the booty please
there's great synergy there between the
dining room and the kitchen and they're
working really well together they're
supporting each other through every
plate
take this come on hurry up take this
hurry up now
[Music]
last four main courses yes yes
the main courses have been badly delayed
but bobby's charm of the dining room has
kept the customers on side and averted a
crisis i don't think we make trick
chickpeas interesting
a big surprise to be honest
i'm really enjoying it it's absolutely
delicious lightly spiced
hotter in the center it's lovely it's
heaven on the plate
even the most ardent carnivores have
been converted
amazing presentation and then the taste
itself was it was it lived up to how it
looked
sometimes i think it was even better
than it looked
you know so i think i think we'll try
and come here again
service is over see ya
bye-bye
and it's time for the prasad team to
hear my verdict
okay um
let's cut to the chase
the
the problem i have
having witnessed
the service is that you've
you've now
just completely
and i mean really completely
blown open this whole competition
you've raised the bar
bobby the communication and making sure
that customers are not agitated waiting
for food you were there
and it sounded amazing me now yes i was
nervous about you but that first ticket
came on and
you were just on fire thank you and
you've made 30 of my diners
the happiest i've ever heard them
that's what i want to hear
do not
go backwards no you maintain and improve
on what you've got
an amazing standard of vegetarian
cuisine it's going to take some beating
my coach load of 30 diners are about to
descend on the second indian restaurant
battling for a place in the semi-finals
of my nationwide restaurant competition
it's the brilliant in london voted for
by you in droves it's been open for 37
years that's almost as long as i've been
around it has three generations of
customers and any russian that can boast
that must be doing something absolutely
spot-on
the anand family have been running this
punjabi restaurant for 40 years with
dipner shankar and dadgulu at the helm
this is a huge ship and to be
right amongst the best it just
encourages us more and more to do even
better
these days gurus retired from the stove
leaving the brilliance kitchen in the
hands of head chef jazz let's get it
going
all the ingredients all the meats they
are cooked freshly
piping hot served to the customers
within seconds the brilliant is known
for its past service
i don't want people waiting for more
than five or six minutes you walk in
here you taste the food and you really
start to believe they've earned their
place
as a frontrunner of indian food in this
country
boasting 220 seats 28 years in the good
food guide and over 80 awards the
brilliant is an indian heavyweight
delicious
[Music]
really good
excellent i'm happy
i'm about to hit them with my first
challenge like prashard they'll also
have just two hours to serve my 30
diners who will arrive in order all at
once
it takes some balls to call it the
brilliant
because you can't be anything less than
brilliant absolutely on a night like
tonight absolutely yeah
we are very confident we've got only 30
diners we're gonna make sure these
guests have a fantastic experience
made this a brilliant service
hi jazz yep yeah
right how's it sounding
really good yeah what are you thinking
of having the prawns and chicken nice on
the menu tonight are two of the house
specialities lamb chops marinated nutmeg
and cardamom and king prawns with fresh
herbs and lime juice both cooked in the
traditional tandoor oven i'm gonna have
the prawns
then i'll go for the prawns two portions
tandoori lamb chops and two tandoori
prawns
but i'm worried head chef jazz is only
using one of the kitchen's two tandoor
ovens two tandoori prawns one tandoori
lamb chop and already tandoori orders
are racking up three prawns one lamb
chops
come on guys let's go surreal how long
for friends five minutes maybe five
minutes yeah you need to get a move on
yet please is there a problem with the
tender oven a little bit because there's
so many tandoori dishes
and why aren't we using two of them
[Music]
it is now but not the beginning that's
what i'm trying to say okay guys please
please get a move on please
this is not brilliant
come on guys please
go to the next one i need this out from
here come on how long for the first lamb
chops please
okay good
it looks like it's been half eaten i've
got another one that looks a little bit
better uh yeah okay the thing is they've
given the cuts so that they eat yeah i
know that if i start eating that and i
go to that it looks like someone's
taking a bite out of it i'm only saying
it for you you can say no gordon that's
how i'm sending it it's fine okay give
me one more piece of lamb chop please
i'm not trying to catch you out you're
not just saying that that's not you at
your best
[Music]
that's beautiful thank you so much two
tables in 45 minutes is a joke
they used to do
200 300 settings 30 we should have been
finished by now
using just one tan door oven has slowed
service to a crawl and orders just
aren't getting out
why is that sat there why can't you go
with that
thing
there's more than one waiter in the
kitchen come on serve the food
please please please
there you go come on
come on come on then
i got bronzing i need the prawns why are
they going in the oven with a cook that
should be gone
help me to understand you
[Music]
they're a bit rubbery excuse me
it's gonna be the longest time i've ever
sat in a new restaurant without being
fed we
it's an unwelcome wake-up call for owner
and ex-head chef gulu
his kitchen needs leadership and jazz
looks lost
the russian's reputation hangs in the
balance
[Music]
okay i need the prawns plates no prawns
in your plates i wound it straight away
in there reacting hurry up boys
get me the prawns all the prawns ready
yeah give me the prawns come on
straight straight ahead
now which
they're nice they're succulent
full of flavour
get this one
let's try and finish yeah yeah
move on guys
okay next i need four meaty chickens
need them piping hot
that's better yeah we're getting there
now some life into the kitchen
a lot more energy in the kitchen that
more importantly the old man's in there
so he's gonna put a rock up their ass
table number five the dishes are there
and now we're now we're fired up yeah
get that on what's the meaning on this
let's take that picture
we've solved everybody
[Music]
it was far from a perfect start but for
my diners the food has really hit the
mark
wow it's gorgeous
food smells amazing
my food's absolutely delicious i
normally go for the standard like creamy
curries um but this was something
completely different and i specifically
asked for it to be milder and they did
it to perfection it was stunning
brilliant
that was absolutely
divine
probably
the best curry i've ever had really
really delicious i'm glad you enjoyed it
[Music]
i love this russian's 40-year pedigree
but tonight they only got it together
after a chaotic start okay
those starters took too long
to leave this kitchen
30 covers tonight felt like 300 covers
it was a little bit too casual but still
it takes time to do the especially the
sanduri stuff which
is
right from the scratch not good enough
this restaurant is not used to sending
out mediocre warm prawns you take a
prawn from that tandoori oven and you
stick it in there
game over
you've got to command that kitchen jazz
from the out
main courses needed a rocket
yeah you put your jacket on bang and it
turned yes the kitchen came to life and
there it was the old man at the helm and
here we go again there was that a fire
in your belly and you got it out don't
get pissed off no no i'm not get eager
to come back you're gonna be
even more stronger now thank you good
night it was a bit bit of a shock to the
system yeah we can still win this we can
we will win this okay good well done
[Music]
my indian restaurants reacted very
differently to the pressure of the coast
trip now i've asked them both to come to
london so i can catch up with them
what they don't realize is that i've
been assessing them secretly i sent in
my own undercover diners to prashad and
the brilliant to see how each restaurant
performed when they had no idea i was
watching and their guard was down
simon davis is a meticulous food critic
who's assessed the food and service at
thousands of restaurants
sarah durden robinson has worked with me
and other top chefs for years helping to
create and perfect thousands of dishes
secret diners are a very useful trick of
the trade and they give you honest
immediate feedback and no holds barred
i've asked sarah and simon to be
deliberately awkward customers to see
how the restaurants cope
[Music]
would you eat that
no so why should i eat it
the teams think they're here to discuss
their performance with my 30 diners they
have no idea what i'm about to show them
first up bradford's prashad
[Music]
food was brilliant
the problem i have now
is that
was that just done for me
or does that restroom function like that
every day every day
how can you say that because we do it
every day we passionately do it every
day
so yes we know is uh what we're doing is
a good because our customers tell us
that was a big test
you've actually been tested twice
after i left i sent in a secret diner
and they secretly filmed
everything
filmed
filmed
[Music]
do we need a reservation or can we just
have some lunch yeah are we okay
can you give me a steer on what to have
yeah i can't really decide what are you
fancy well i'm feeling quite hungry
hungry yeah i'm feeling quite hungry uh
things not to miss if you're sharing uh
would be petice and would be charred and
where's this is this mainly southern
india no this is northern no we're from
north india right a good job should it
be similar to rajasthani or uh no no
rajasthan is a lot more rich and deeper
whereas ours is a lot more delicate
right
okay knowledgeable
great
first interaction with the divers the
food will speak for itself you know we
have that as a given so it's up to me to
kind of make that person feel
comfortable if they have questions to
answer them openly and with as much
information as they can give so let's
try one of these should we go
award-winning platoons first
[Music]
love that coconut it's really clever
that
through i mean i ate that probably
20 30 seconds ago and it's tasting
different flavors are still coming
through
i'm just going to
swap a curry quite late in the day um
let's see what they do
excuse me can i change one of my curries
could i it's all right
any goats any any special handy i think
yeah
bags
that's a good guy i couldn't have dealt
with that better
you could ask you could say that this
one do we have a bit more punch in this
one
let's see if you can play around with
that is there anything you can do to
make that one a little bit hotter
a little bit more hotter yeah how hot do
you want it we're not not to the degree
that you know you just laugh at us when
we walk out the door
[Music]
i love them and that came back like a
fresh dish
no hassle at all it's so refreshing to
see that level of flexibility
there's no intimidation you're not
making them feel awkward there's no
guilt if i if i hadn't behaved that way
in front of my customers i know two
people in the kitchen would have been
very angry at me
you could easily look past this place
and never come in actually
surprisingly it's got some of the best
indian food i've probably ever eaten
it's blown me away with it it's been
really fantastic fresh
well-sourced
expertly done and done with passion and
knowledge
[Music]
pretty well done thank you
you made me feel nervous because you
raised the bar so high i didn't think
you could do that again
oh my god leave
i'm feeling fantastic you know
gordon ramsay big big man um telling me
that you know everything we're doing is
good we were nervous before i just can't
contain it
so far prasad are punching way above
their weight but i have concerns over
how much this tiny ration depends on
bobby's front of house charm
tonight two fantastic indian restaurants
are battling it out in my nationwide
competition to find my best restaurant
somebody pass the puri please
now it's time for london restaurant the
brilliant to find out i've been snooping
on them
unknown
to all of you once i left the brilliant
i then sent in
my secret diners and this is what they
saw
on the coach trip head chef jazz failed
to take control of the kitchen and at
times the food suffered owner gulu had
to step up to the tandoor to save the
day have the brilliant learn from their
mistakes
hello
table for two for a little bit early we
asked for minor problems i wanted to
take this
[Music]
thank you
so much
it's very distracting it's like in a pub
when they've got the television on and
everyone ends up going
i don't know if i'm in a nightclub or a
restaurant
is there any way you can turn them turn
the noise down a bit thank you
oh god that's so much better
you're in charge of the service um whose
idea is all those screens and the music
they've been around for
quite a while and some customers
actually like them are quite adapted to
the idea but then you do obviously get a
clash sometimes and
when when we are asked we do mellow it
down
[Music]
fresh mint chutney it's fantastic it's
mouth-watering it's so fresh
it's absolutely delicious
these chocolates are really great
so many different things so many
different flavors
it really gets your palette and your
appetite going
nice really good start fresh clean
chutneys exciting vibrant and a really
nice way of relaxing customers really
nice way
one of the problems i've had about this
place is they leave your feet on the hot
way too long
that'll be the real test
hello thank you
something's just come out of the tumbler
they should be sizzling and plumping
juicy and these are just not they are
definitely still
overcropped
uh jazz prawns why they're coming out
overcooked still as soon as we take the
prawns out quickly served in i'd ask you
to look at that seriously in terms of
attempting to cook them less i think
what we need to do is every portion of
prawns that goes out this week do one
extra prawn and test it before it goes
out because that's something that we
need to work on
i'm about to send the masala back to see
what they say but i'm going to say it's
not spicy enough for me i'd like it a
little hotter i want to see what they do
hello
said on the money that it was spicy
that was which is spicy it's weird
because i like really hot food
and this guy's right it's very mild what
thank you very much thanks
amazing
[Music]
um
this is really awful
but i maybe change it for something else
that's really kind thank you
so patient so tolerated
third time lucky thank you very much
this is delicious
this is even better than the last two
dishes
yeah this is a slick operation
i love it i love that excitement
customer's always right that's what
they're paying for you can adapt the
customer's needs
great
it didn't start well
but
that's the end of the meal and i am so
happy and i don't think they could have
looked after me any better i don't think
they could handle
my constant complaints or any better i
don't think they could be more
professional the food is outstanding
when the food arrives they love the food
when the service matches the food you
have something quite
exciting there
jazz i
want you to step up to the mark
i need to do something
i think
i'm a bit nervous right now but later on
i'm going to develop the confidence we
will be doing that valuable feedback
that was absolutely amazing we've got to
be so positive
to make sure that we
learn from the mistakes
my undercover evidence has hit them hard
now they need to learn from this
experience there's no time to waste
because both restaurant chefs are about
to face their biggest challenge yet
[Music]
i'll be taking them out of their
kitchens and into mine
i've asked them to create and cook a
dish that lives up to the standards at
my three michelin star restaurant
very nice
i'm very very very exciting today to
cooking in the gordon ramsay's
restaurant i'm putting her my hundred
percent thought in it
it's a dream for every chef to cook
for a three-star restaurant and i'm
looking forward in winning this
competition
tonight
one of them will win a place in the
semi-finals and one will be eliminated
[Music]
this is my dream here everything i've
ever worked for it's a small beautiful
restaurant and it's an amazing place for
both of your restaurants today to really
shine i asked you to come here to take
it to a different level with your food
and really aspire to do something unique
at the end of it sadly there's only one
restaurant that's going through the
semi-final
make sure it's you good luck thank you
i've challenged both chefs to create one
exquisite course
big amount of pressure on their
shoulders today because they've got to
develop and involve those dishes into
something stunning i'm expecting a dish
that's perfectly spiced with delicious
textures and sublime flavors
but it's not just me they have to
impress i've invited 20 guests who know
their barges from their brewery's to
come and try both restaurants dishes
including inarm ali founder of the
british curry awards and respected
indian cookbook author and broadcaster
manju mali
all my diners will try both restaurants
dishes
each restaurant's front of house teams
are here as my yes and i'll be watching
the chef's every move and there's
nowhere to hide
okay first to get on it's for the
brilliance at four covers away table six
yeah four gel frazee oh keisha
tonight the brilliant are taking on
prasad at their own game cooking a
vegetarian take on a much-loved classic
paneer jalfrezi
jazzy's recipe matches chili laden
indian curd cheese with a sauce flavored
with a unique blend of 15 spices
i'm making our own cheese today wow
isn't that a bit crazy on a day like
today chef i'm in your restaurant i have
to do something crazy
this is the type of flourish jazz needs
to live this classic dish to new heights
opportunities like these never knocked
on your doors that's the reason why i'm
working so hard i want to achieve
something today
and i'm excited to see chef sunil making
a speciality rarely found in the uk
paper-thin ramali roti
an order the brilliant four covers away
table one
[Music]
guys look at me just like a normal
restaurant i need an answer right well
you don't answer me i'm just gonna stop
and look at you again okay because like
you do in your kitchen you get a
response but i'm calling out tickets and
no one's responding just acknowledge
what i'm saying right otherwise i just
go like this [ __ ] it stick the tickers
up there and i've got to call it out for
joel frazee
thank you welcome back
so far in this competition head chef
jazz has produced some stunning
traditional punjabi cuisine for the
brilliant but on occasion he's lost
control of the kitchen his food has
missed the mark and owner gulu has had
to save the day you've got no glue in
the kitchen today yeah you don't need
him in the kitchen do you
no well you've got your work cut out the
heat's on yeah this is the biggest
moment in our history
of the brilliant tonight the hopes and
dreams of the brilliant rest on jazz's
shoulders
we're serving food clinging on like
something coming out of a juice dog's
[ __ ] table one let's go
first dish coming from brilliant thank
you good job crazy
smells good i like the paneer nice and
soft
[Music]
stunning kofta yes yes
prashad are making vegetable kofta
steamed and spiced chopped vegetables
encased in a potato patty deep fried
then served in a fresh tomato sauce
the sauce is quite hot medium spices but
lots of flavor in it
[Music]
just don't put those
koftas in there too early because it's
starting to break up a vegetable coffee
is very hard to get right because so
many elements they can explode and sort
of disintegrate getting the time and
right on this dish is critical so manal
and kalshi need to work together
perfectly for me
this is lovely just you need to be a bit
faster i am partly look at here what are
you doing come on give me your time
hello just a minute in her own kitchen
minnow struggled with the pressure and
only just came out on top and tonight
there's no supportive husband bobby in
the kitchen to help her
by now i'm pretty sure if i know minnow
and my mum they'll be right in the
middle of the cooking and just totally
focused on giving you the best food
[Music]
but this is my kitchen and my now's way
out of a comfort zone
hey anybody seen my onion it was here
look at me after every table we have to
clear down we can't continue working in
a mess yeah thank you look after your
ingredients yeah
come on mom can i have that please mommy
do you have some more butter
come on guys oh god mom come on ladies
what are you looking for
what are you looking for me now joe
please yeah i need one more button
thank you service go let's go please
no it's four
that's it four don't worry about that
it's four listen to me listen to me i'm
here i'm here to help you you're
confusing yourself not me fall away
please thank you oh
it's a very
very very lot of pressure
we and mumbo are going through a lot of
praise a lot to do
it's very complicated this so it's neat
time so that's why i'm
i'm just
[Music]
please how's everybody very happy
[Music]
this is very very good it's a lovely
shape the presentation is
immaculate and beautiful looking it's
really nice isn't it last table please
me now kelsey four cops are away
nice
very nice
little clear down both of you well done
[Music]
so hard
service is over so it's time to discover
what my distinguished guests thought of
both restaurants dishes starting with
the brilliant yes really good to see
let's talk the
jeff frazee how was that for you the
first i think combination is very good
also the paneer also i found is tasty
it's not only
the cheese it has got a spice yes
presentation also remarkable ramali roti
that's very very traditional this is
very hard to make i was really nervous
i am now relieved
they've done a fabulous job
the koftas were nice nice
and delicious and you could taste the
fresh ginger so that was great it looked
good as well i think the prussian dish
is awesome
the only thing i'd say bryce is supposed
to be nice and fluffy and separate
they've got somehow they've got this bit
strong
right but overall i think this is
excellent phenomenally proud the dish
that they've made today you know i
definitely think that we've done our
very best
my diners clearly love the food though
neither restaurant quite achieve
perfection
now it's up to me to choose a winner
whatever i decide will affect the future
of both these restaurants
if i lose today i will be breakdown i
need to win i really need to win this
competition but
i don't know i'm so panicking we're
definitely going to win i think we gave
our full hundred percent into it and
i think we have done a good job only one
indian restaurant can go through to the
semi-finals
and after tonight's service the decision
is gonna be tougher than ever
my two top indian restaurants the
brilliant from london and prasad from
bradford have completed their final
challenge
they are both exceptional restaurants
but one of them is about to be
eliminated
to help me make my choice i'm going to
taste each of their dishes
[Music]
the kofta it's a very different one to
get ryan those vegetables
bound with a potato and that rich tomato
gravy the downside a little bit of
fapping around unnecessary on the plate
i'd rather see one big stunning one as
opposed to three individual ones
cut in the middle you can see those
vegetables
oh my god
pretty tasty
the right amount of heat and that nice
textured coffee
rice
shame the rice actually lets it down
it's overcooked
brilliant
gel frazee chili's everywhere
red and green chili
and the secret of this gel crazy is the
the texture
and the balance of the heat
they've got the heat correct and masala
it definitely needs that right to cool
it down paneer delicious
handmade and made here and that takes a
lot of skill the only issue i have there
is the the rawness the vegetables those
crunchy peppers are sort of spoiling the
texture of the joffrey both restaurants
felt the pressure here today and both of
them haven't hit it 100
now they've fallen short at the last
hurdle both questions
[Music]
two outstanding indian restaurants but
only one can win a place in the next
round
[Music]
okay
first of all
that was a very
interesting service
i could identify
issues
from both
restaurants
in a way that i didn't expect
from brilliant
pinergy phrasing sumptuous
delicious
finding that balance with the masalas is
a tough one
love the way you had the balls to make
that premier
the one issue i had was the
the rawness of the vegetables the
peppers were barely cooked
and it didn't completely spoil the dish
but it didn't enhance it
prashad i thought the koftas were a bold
move
loved the vegetables inside delicious
the gravy was seasoned beauty and had
that right amount of heat
the big shot for me was the
the overcooked rice
i've eaten in your restaurant and i know
how well you cook
and i didn't expect to see overcooked
rice
today this competition is not going to
be won or lost on one dish alone
i'm looking for the best restaurant in
britain
brilliant
i turn up with a coach load of diners 30
of them jumping into the restaurant
eager to taste that food
we got off to a sluggish start
but my god
did those diners
enjoy that food i sent in my secret
diners
and again
i've never seen a resident so
excited to help
when it's not even their fault
good sign
[Music]
prasad
i turn up
in the back of beyond of bradford 30
diners could have barely fit in
the pressure was
immense
however
they loved the food
then i sent in my secret diner
and peeled up the food
[Music]
this is a tough one
a very tough one
sadly
there's only one restaurant going
through to the semi-final
the restaurant going through
based on everything
i've seen and tasted
[Music]
it's precise
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
well done
that restaurant will continue being
unique there's no two ways about that
and that was for me one of the tightest
and the closest decisions i've ever had
to make
another journey of 35 years
we've won
numerous awards
and uh
we'll be we'll be back again right the
the show carries on and the brilliant
will carry on congratulations
thank you thank you
well done
are you okay
really well done
and
i'm i'm so happy thank you for the
family and for the restaurant why
because the food is extraordinary
thank you thank you thank you well done
thanks very much i'm so happy i can't
even think about it so happy i'm so
happy it was really difficult for me
because i wasn't in there every single
step of the way as a family whenever we
perform we're always together service
kitchen everything together today i had
to sit back and
look like i was enjoying food i didn't
have an appetite at all but you know
we're just
i can't i can't tell you fantastic what
an extraordinary day and i'm quite sad
to say goodbye to brilliant but
you've got to give it up for prasar they
were amazing now the competition really
starts with them they're through the
semi-finals and they are going to have
to really really pull the stops out
you